good evening and welcome to statford on
aan District Council planning committee
my name is councelor Lewis Adam I'm your
chairman for this evening uh some
housekeeping to begin with uh there's
not a fire alarm plan so if one does go
off uh please make an Oly exit the must
point is in the car park across the road
by the pub um it is a public meeting uh
sorry a meeting in public not a public
meeting so those um permitted uh
registered speak are permitted to do so
U I'll call you forward at the
appropriate time and give you further
instructions at that point um please
make sure your phones are off or at
least silent so that they don't uh
disrupt the flow of the meeting and the
meeting will be broadcast on our website
and recorded um the top table um this
evening from democra Services is K
Keller we have our solicor Amy Shipley
our planning manager is Al cosnet and
uh got to get my list
of planning officers so we've got
Victoria Kempton we have Ryan O'Keefe
and sorry Sarah Le Sarah Leech apology
Sarah um it's been a bit of a busy day
already um I believe Alice has a
statement she's prepared I do thank you
chairman my role is to provide imp
partial advice and to assist members in
their decision
taking thank you very much okay we can
now move on to our agenda um item one
apologies for absence we have apologies
from councilor's Curtis and Parry with
councelor score as substitute lovely
thank you very much welcome councilor
scora um item two disclosures of
Interest members do have any disclosures
of interest uh counc Fleming
first yeah um I I'm Ward member for item
four for uh bidford on aen so I'll be
stepping out because I'm going to speak
on it
anyway all right good thank you
councelor
Harvey
to uh familiarize myself with the site
without talking to anybody so I'm just
aware of the positioning of The Proposal
thank you thank you very much councilor
Harvey um actually I've got a similar
declaration along those lines um and
yeah I think we all do and from my
personal point of view I have work uh
which relates to a property in the
village but is unrelated to this uh site
or application and I approached the item
with an open mind
okay any further Declarations of
Interest oh councilor keithy thank you
chair just the same I'd visited site but
I'd stayed on the um the main road and
walk the dog so I've seen the um the
location really good thank you very much
okay uh there oh sorry counc Pon thank
you chair uh application 23 oblique
01872 very um I'm the adjoining Ward
member uh I've not had any uh
involvements in the VAR
application uh so again uh although a
joining Ward member happy that I come
come to it with an open
mind thank you very much Council pemon
anything else from Members no in which
case we can move on to item three which
is our first application um application
23842 ful Waters Edge hunington shipston
Stow um our presenting officer is
Victoria Kempton when you're ready take
get
away thank you chairman and good evening
this application is seeking permission
for a replacement dwelling and other
alterations including changes to the
access gate the site is identified by
the black dot on the map which lies in
the village of Huntington this is around
one mile to the north of
shipston the site is outlined in red on
the plan which is within the Huntington
Conservation Area I've sketched the
position of a grade two star listed
registered Park and Garden as outlined
in green uh which lies to the north and
east of the
site as discussed within the report home
farm and the Stone Barn are the two
grade two listed buildings opposite the
site these plans show the elevations of
the proposed dwelling which would have a
ridge height of around 8.4 M the front
elevation contains a range of window
sizes in addition to positions whilst
the rear re of elevation includes a
large gend window the front elevation
would also be finished in Natural Stone
whilst the side and rear elevations
would have a rendered
finish the proposed dwelling would be
laid out to provide two bedrooms
although two studies could facilitate
two further bedrooms resulting in a
four-bedroom
dwelling the proposed site plan shows
the new dwelling having a revised
sighting which is around 5 m closer to
the eastern boundary the dwelling would
also be slightly angled away from the
highway to align the rear elevation with
the rear
boundary secondly the plan indicates the
changes to the boundary wall with the
removal of a 1.8 m cob section by the
entrance and the addition of a new
pedestrian and vehicular access
gate the retained parts of the pool area
is also shown in blue although the
application has not been supported by
scaled elevations of these parts of the
development these photos illustrate how
the existing dwelling is Red from the
highway having a recessive and lowlevel
appearance these photos show how the
site is red within the street scene with
the site being indicated by the arrows
the first image shows the relationship
of the property to the grade two listed
home Farm which is this one and the
Stone Barn which is just behind which
lie opposite the site the second image
shows the position of the grade two star
listed registered Park and garden which
wraps around the side and re of the site
around
here you can see that the site is within
a central position and promis prominent
location with within the village whilst
being within the setting of key Heritage
assets sorry the street scene is
dominated by a large number of
significant buildings in terms of
history and architecture and these are
some examples of the prominent and more
important bu buildings within the
village the con conservation officer has
highlighted that many of these are not
only Heritage Assets in their own right
but combined to create one of the best
conservation areas in the district The
Village backdrop to the adjacent grade
two star listed registered Park and
garden to the rear um is also very
rare as discussed in the report key
design characteristics include the Steep
roof pitches with narrow spans stone and
brick materials chimneys and simple
window openings there are more modern
properties within the village although
these are not as prominent as the
buildings highlighted
above this aial image further
demonstrates the proximity of the site
to the the 18th century registered Park
and
garden overall the recommendation is for
refusal for the reasons outlined in the
officer's report there are some updates
also on the update sheet and this
concludes my presentation thank you
chairman thank you very much Victoria um
okay uh we'll now move on to our first
Speaker who is Allison Morris who's the
clerk from Huntington Parish Council
good
evening so you've got three three
minutes um are you happy for me to give
you a 30 second
warning okay no is yeah but on the I
will assume that you've all read the
submission that I sent to Victoria which
is on page three of your pack and out of
that I just want to make three main
points I mean I'm here to speak as the
elected Parish Clerk of hunington Parish
meeting and my role is to represent the
Village
Voice what you will see from that is
that as Parish Clerk I've spoken to
almost every resident and with only one
exception they are in favor of this new
planning application the unanimous view
is that both the approved design which
was approved earlier and the latest are
significant improvements on the current
building
universally residents dislike the
current building
intensely the um they feel that it has a
significantly negative impact on the
character of the street scene and look
forward to it being replaced with
something
else secondly nobody wants a pasti of
one of the wonderful Tuda Georgian
Victorian or
cotwell laborers
cottages The Village has evolved since
the Doomsday Book and a new building
therefore will be a continuation in
their own times the Georgian buildings
were brand new and did not fit with the
other existing
buildings thirdly if this current
application is
rejected I firmly believe that Mr
Chambers will revert to his earlier
approved
application this one is smaller more
compact more ecologically
friendly and I think it would be a
missed opportunity to start to move
forward with the more modern design but
in entirely appropriate materials he
spent a lot of time checking against the
the character listed and I think it
would be a shame if it was turned
down thank
you thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for the representative from the parish
council coun keatley yeah thank you very
much um we have an updated report here
um from the conservation officer and I
was just going to ask whether or not
you'd had a chance to see it as had the
residents chance to read it as
well so I've not the opportunity to it
to Residence okay thank
you
any further
questions no in which case thank you
very much for your
contribution okay we now move on then to
our next speaker who is Mr Nick Chambers
the
applicant good evening Mr
chus if if that's how You' be most
comfortable that's fine as long as the
microphone is on and and we can hear you
um that's fine um likewise you've got
three minutes um I'm happy to give you a
30 second warning if you'd like yes
please yeah okay in which case when
you're ready take it away sure so I send
you some photographs which I'll go
through fairly quickly because I believe
they've just been put up hunington yes
was sort of settled thousand years ago
Anglo-Saxon settlement largely by the
river which is off to the left hand side
and then up in the rge and F farming
where to the right hand side so having
looked through from an archaeological
perspective the closest finding is is
about 200 M away in little hunington so
there's been a lot of development in the
village over the last 50 years about
five houses and lots of alterations and
no archaeological findings have been
found in all that time so as you'll see
from the next photograph The Waters Edge
site was established in 1960 as a
subdivision of the one on the left which
is the Old Forge used to be a garden
pigs were kept there I'm told and you
can see it's been very extensive
developed including a swimming pool
about 2 m deep so again no
archaeological findings from any of that
so somebody said the chance of any more
archaeologic findings you got more
chance of finding Life on
Mars now some of the key buildings um I
think we've just seen before we might
move on to a few more
photographs yet we've seen that
photograph already um and and that one
yes so now we get into the yeah I guess
public views on the exist existing
building now in the 1970 hunington
conservation report it refers to
reconstituted Stone saying it's a shame
that a building was allowed to be
developed and almost certainly that
refers to Water's Edge so that's
entirely consistent with residents views
so I have discussed in the last few days
I've met with 19 residents taken them
through the findings of the report and
none of them would say that it's neutral
in character all of them said that it's
negative many of them very negative so
they're all looking forward to
replacement dwelling and you can
probably see
why yes next photograph similar sort of
show that um you'll see the orange
shining and the electricity cables
because that's put being put in place by
a National Grid because the house is
started to be demolished um I do see
some reference to say that the the um
you know my my application which has
already been approved is somehow
theoretical I strongly dispute it's
theoretical I've about building control
approval I've had demolition approval
I've started demolition um after tonight
I will be going back to what's been
already approved if this new one doesn't
get approved the existing dwelling
suffered right major water damage so
anyway let's skip through a few more
photographs yeah so pretty ugly yeah
that's the view from home Farm he's
strongly against the existing dwelling
strongly in favor of the new proposal
that's the view out of his bedroom
similar this is the view from the
Parklands pretty ugly looking
building right Windows some sort of
criticisms of the windows if you
actually look to I'll have to ask you to
try and wrap it up as quickly as all all
all the houses around have got
discordant sort of window patterns so I
don't think that's an issue so in
summary I have supplied plans on the
elevations of Conservatory um gate see
sorry if you could wrap it up for there
please go right I think I better just
take questions yeah thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
applicant Catholic e yeah thank you very
much chair uh Mr Chambers thanks very
much for that those photographs I'm just
interested in this archaeological issue
um the planning officers are are saying
to us that there is insufficient
evidence provided to to to to consider
whether or not there might be some harm
arising from the development um had you
considered having an archaeological
report as a result of those
conversations with the planning officers
to to cover off that matter it certainly
didn't get raised in any conversation
I've only had one conversation with the
planning officer um but I did see that
she said in the middle of September yes
we would recommend an archaeological so
she then referred me to warshire County
Council so I did speak with Mr John
Robinson there and he described the
process of looking through the
historical environment database uh which
I duly did and it identified to say the
three closest findings about 200 meters
away so I did then submit this to the
planning officer on the 10th of October
the the initial findings and I also
offered to say clearly as a planning
condition that if further by a qualified
archaeologist if they need to do the
same thing as a desktop survey as I very
straightforward process and then they
needed to be present during the
excavation of the footings
absolutely okay thank you very much for
that any other questions for applicant
no which case oh oh sorry last second
Council
pattingham um you you say that the um
this application is for a smaller
building that is more environmentally
friendly in what way is it more
environmentally friendly than the last
application okay so the right so the
current building I think I've sent
through some figures on the it had an
energy performance certificate rating of
e which is pretty awful and so you know
already a new building footprint is
going to save half the sort of you know
emissions of that so the one that was
approved back in March um I've got some
figures but it was a reduction in in
square footprint by about 50 square
meters and would of course you know
comply with all the current u values so
the approved one would reduce the sort
of carbon emission say from 12 tons down
to six now the proposed one is going to
have underfloor heating air source heat
pump and with solar panels which have
been accepted then that will reduce it
down to two tons per year of carbon
emissions so fairly significant savings
which I would say a fairly significant
ific public
benefits another quick question um that
the the new proposal seem to have
references to Georgian buildings the the
Symmetry and the and the porch at the
front would would the the planning
permission that was passed is it the
same style as as the your current
application in in terms of not at all I
I did send R some information which may
may not have come through in a p F which
does a direct comparison between the
approved and the
proposed and I I say I I sent I sent it
through I don't know if it'd be
previously sent through but it's been
sent through multiple times to the
planning officer and and to Alice as
well and it's a direct comparison now
the one that was previously approved um
was obviously taking the existing
building um going up I think 1.7 MERS um
keeping the existing windows and then
putting off a wing to the left hand side
um essentially where the swimming pool
is and the advantage of the proposed is
it makes a much neater condensed sort of
two-story footprint um which certainly
has gone you know by by virtue of making
it a a sort of more rectangular shape
then it will improve its heat loss um
you know considerably because it's got
less I'll just interject and say um the
officers say that they do have those
elevations and so we can maybe raise
that at a points clarification for any
further information okay any further
questions for
applicant no in which case thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening thank you um okay so uh there
are no further registered speakers but
the ward member councelor littlewood has
provided a statement that he's asked me
to read out and I'm happy to do so uh so
I'm I'm just going to do that and then
we'll move on to points clarification uh
so from the Ward member I initially
supported this application to replace a
dilapidated building with a new building
of modern construction and energy
efficient design sympathetic to the
sensitivity of the location and with a
potential to enhance the existing Street
Scene the application site is within a
the conservation area and backs onto a
grade two star listed Parkland Garden
the hunington Clark to the parish
meeting has conducted a straw pole of
members of the village and has reported
that those who were consulted were in
favor of a replacement building and has
entered comment of no objection as have
I the process from validation to
determination has not been
straightforward as I understand it the
officer has received several amendments
that have not been accepted in addition
there Remain the problems that one the
submitted elevations of the retained
part of the dwelling gate and front
boundary wall were drawn in an
unrecognized scale to the submitted
archaeological information has not been
carried out by qualifi archaeologist who
is a registered member of the chartered
Institute of
archaeologists I have suggested to the
applicant that withdrawal of the
application with a resubmission having
corrected items one and two and any
other issues that might be material
would be the best way to proceed quoting
the officer statement on page six of the
recommendations the loss of existing
dwelling is therefore not resisted in
fact a replacement dwelling has the
potential to enhance the character of
the conservation
area uh I am um I am unable to support
this application in its present form but
support the principle of replacement um
to replace an isore in the form of the
of the existing structure with an
acceptable design
and as I said that's from the Ward
member uh councelor lwood um okay we can
now move on then to points of
clarification
um sorry we we can't take any further
points from the from the floor at this
point councelor Harvey thank you
chairman um Victoria page
13 um you make a reference in in the
summary in the larger paragraph second
paragraph to insufficient public
benefits to to overcome uh any any harm
and in your number one reason you also
State there are no public benefits that
have been identified to outweigh the
harm um the applicant's case is that
there is public benefit because of the
reduction in CO2 that would arise from
the uh revised energy uh output from
from from the building so I have a
two-prong question really are you really
saying that there are in this case no
public benefits or are you saying that
there are insufficient public benefits
is question one and question two is
could you outline to us what you think
would be sufficient public benefit that
would persuade you to uh indicate that
the the public benefits were sufficient
to outweigh the
harm thank you counselor um so in the um
in the assessment it does it does
consider other benefits in that U there
may be um a self builded exemption as
part of the sale form um but in in
answer to your question there are no
public benefits identified to outweigh
the harm identified so whilst there are
some public benefits they are they do
not outweigh the harm identified now the
harm is less than substantial harm to
the character and significance of the
conservation area less than substantial
harm to the setting of the grade two
star listed registered Park and garden
and less than substantial harm to the um
listed buildings opposite the site that
is in addition to insufficient
information regarding the archaeology
and the plans so there is both
insufficient public benefits submitted
so overall there are no public benefits
that would outweigh the harm ident
ified counil
pton thank you chair um so your position
is that there is less than substantial
harm okay and do you maintain that
position given the um final sentence of
the penultimate paragraph of the
conservations officer who says the
result would seriously compromise the
character of the area and the setting of
the nearby listed buildings
um it seems to me that your position is
that having assessed everything and
taken the view of the conservation
officer that you take a different view
in that he he is talking about serious
compromise and you talking about less
than substantial I just want to clarify
that that is your position as the
assessing case officer even in light of
this
update I have been in Communications
with Robert um and the conservation
officer um and as part of informal
discussions he was of the agreement with
the less and substantial harm identified
the less and substantial meets the um
criteria set out in the mppf for
identifying harm to listed or Heritage
assets and just to add to that I think
um the fact that the conservation
officer identifies something with the
scheme will seriously compromise the
term less than substantial is such a
wide term so although it sound sounds
like it's not a lot of harm that
seriously compromising still Falls
within that umbrella of less than
substantial so that's why it doesn't
seem quite right that the conservation
officer is saying it's seriously
compromises and we're saying it's less
some substantial but that has been
agreed with the conservation officer and
that's what we need to give great weight
to any harm to Heritage
assets thank you um for the points of
clarification councelor
passingham my point about how does this
application vary from the application
that has already been approved you've
got some photos some
drawings thank you I'll just upload them
now so these are the approved extensions
um I've included a slight comparison of
the plans and how they relate to the
proposed plans within the report um but
these were the householder
extensions
right
yeah any further points of
clarification no in which case we can
move on to debate who would like to
start anyone itching to go cast Harvey
uh I'm quite happy to
go I can understand um no I'll start off
by saying my eye for um what's beautiful
and what's not beautiful is not
wonderful um but I can accept that
residents of Huntington aren't in love
with the existing building leave it at
that
um the officer gives three reasons for
her recommendation to
refuse uh starting in reverse order um
it seems to me that the the question of
the gate and so on from what I've seen
is is a soluble matter um I don't see
that as been a a deal breaker so to
speak the question of the archaeology
can be sorted out there are different
opinion there may be different opinions
about what the potential archaeological
value of the site is but that could be
conditioned and sorted
out the critical question is is reason
number one and I think that the critical
opinion is that of the conservation
officer
because although I hear the Clark from
the parish council reporting on the
views of 19 residents planning is not a
popularity contest planning decisions
have to be made on the basis of planning
policy and planning
reasons um the update we've been given
from the conservation officer is set out
in my in in my appraisal in in very
strident and clear terms he has firmly
of the view that this building the
proposed
building will cause harm substantial or
otherwise we we could debate that but um
when he uses phrases like um uh no merit
or um a the result would seriously
compromise the character of the area the
whole point of of officers going to the
conservation officer is to get the view
of of an experienced and um
knowledgeable individual uh who who's
not just giving opinions in the sort of
way that I as a lay person might give
but he is giving based he is giving his
views based upon his experience and his
expertise um from my point of view I
don't think I have any grounds for
questioning the strident way in which
the conservation officer has made his
views known and and I I think that is a
deal breaker uh I I I I don't see that
it is possible to find an alternate view
with with equal credibility to say the
opposite to what the conservation
officer has said and given that we have
to respond and make our decisions based
upon planning reasons uh for me this is
uh a clear reason why we can't approve
this this application and why I would go
along with the officer's recommendation
to refuse regretful though it is in the
sense of there are at least 19 Villages
who want to get rid of an Isa and I
understand that but but my vote will go
based on on planning considerations
thank you thank you very much councilor
Harvey uh who would like to go next
Council
pton thank you
um it's not often that councelor Harvey
and I are not on the same page but this
is going to be one of those rare
occasions um design impact on a
Conservation Area impact on a
setting the phrase Eye of the Beholder
this is entirely subjective it is not
objective there is no demonstrably
measurable yard stick that anybody can
use so as decision makers we are in the
in this application absolutely in the
Realms of
balancing and bringing a view informed
by planning training informed by
planning uh
understanding I am minded
that at the moment there is
demonstrably a harm to the setting of
the conservation area by the current
building it if that building was before
us as a new build it wouldn't even have
got this far it's it's there by an
accident of previous and that's
is what it is but it doesn't add and I
think the conservation officer is
absolutely stridden in his antipathy to
this
building but I look at a design and I
look at an approach and I look at
something and I think the Clark
mentioned it's not a pasti it's
definitely not a
pasti I think there is an element there
where it is a more modern twist
on uh providing a solution and there are
we have been shown pictures of an idio
idiosyncratic set of buildings they're
not
uniform and from my
perspective there is absolutely some
harm because it's a it's a it's a
two-story building versus a you so there
is some harm but I'm not minded that it
is so
substantial um as to as so I I I am I'm
I I I'll hear the rest of the debate but
I'm actually not leaning towards
supporting the recommendation because I
think actually this is a a this is a
good solution and it is a solution that
in 50 years time we'll look at a
building and feel that it is sympathetic
in accordance with what else is around
it it doesn't strike me as so
domineering to the garden for example um
that it that it destroys its value so
that's where I currently am with it but
I'll wait to hear what other members of
the committee have got to say thank you
very much Council pemon who would like
to go next councel Keithley thank you
chair um well that was interesting to
hear councilor pemberton's view on this
um I took a I took a walk down the
Village um I could hardly see the
existing building so whether or not the
existing building is harmful to that
area or not is also
subjective right so if you're going to
say that a new building is a subjective
issue then so is the existing one it's
small it's recessive you can't really
notice it but I can understand that
residents don't really like it it looks
like a 60s Bungalow stuck in the wrong
place uh that said um what I've looked
at in the plans the elevations of The
Proposal is something that is really
quite substantial in Mass and I would I
would feel that a replacement dwelling
is the right thing to do but I think the
design of what's proposed is at the
moment not quite right um it is much
broader um it's is Big the windows I've
read the report on on the conservation
officer saying you know the windows
don't quite look right you talked about
pasti going to copy what's there
opposite I get that but you know you're
talking about somebody with a great deal
of experience in these things in my view
um I would like to see something come
forward that was a little bit
less um intrusive on that particular
area particularly as you walk down the
road you see that building is set
against the Parkland behind it is a very
very obvious plot um the actual
properties's moved up a little bit as
well so it impacts on the views that you
get through the two big trees on on on
the roads side as well um I think it's
the right thing to do to come forward
with a replacement dwelling and I can
understand why the applicant has done
that and my sense is that on on on the
basis of the existing designs that were
in front of us um I I would find it
extremely difficult to go against the
view of the conservation officer and as
councilor Harvey said those other issues
you know what exactly what the gate
looks like and whether or not the
archaeology can be sorted out they're
relatively minor things but but the mass
of that new building the depth of it
position of the the windows and
everything um it it that is the that is
the thing that is not going to be
changed if it gets built so so I I hear
what you say councelor pton and I I I
kind of get that we want something there
and I can understand why we would be
happy to approve a replacement but at
the moment what I see in the designs I'm
I'm not supportive of
um I'm afraid I'm going to have to go
with councelor Harvey on his summary of
the
situation thank you very much uh
councilor passingham
next uh well I go along with councilor
of
pton um uh I I hear what what the
conservation officer has said and uh I'm
I'm must admit I can't fully see what
that there's great harm in this it
certainly uh an improvement on the
existing building and to me it looks a
vast Improvement on the the approved
plans for a new building um which uh um
don't really add anything they're in the
same vein as the existing building
really they're an extension to a to a
60s Bungalow whereas the the design for
the new one has got references in a way
to the other buildings in the village
there's a lot of symmetry in the windows
the porch um uh but it's not a pasti it
it's it looks like a a quite a modern
building but in in done in Good Taste to
me so I would say and I I think it's
important obviously that it's more
environmentally friendly and there's a
vast saving in terms of carbon emissions
with this and um so those two benefits
to me outweigh the conservation
officer's recommendation so I'll be
going um um to um um yeah against the
recommendation okay thank you Council
passingham um I'll add my thoughts at
this point I'm more in agreement with
councilors Harvey and Keith Le
personally um I think well actually the
the ward member particularly I think
there's a shared um understanding that
this the existing building is not what
people want there and is less sensitive
than would be liked for the area I do
think however that the replacement is
there is a in incredibly High bar to
what that replacement should be um the
environmental credentials are laudable
and I think that's right but I'd also
expect that that would be the case of
any building that would um be approved
for that um and that the design elements
of that building should one be approved
um should also meet the other
requirements that are set out by the
conservation officer I think the
conservation officers incredibly
eloquent in the way in which um they've
put their their thoughts together and
that there are ways in which um one
could produce a scheme not too far away
from what we got in front of us uh that
would meet those um th that bar but at
the moment what we've got in front of us
does not reach that limit um those are
my thoughts and um yeah I'll I'll leave
it at that I'm aware we've not had a
formal proposal um as of yet for a
suddenly people are itching to go um
I'll go to council Harvey and then I've
got other speakers on the list PR
refuse thank you very much um Council
hin was that thank you chair um I
totally agree with councelor Keithley uh
there could be a better street view
design of this building to match
existing building so uh I will be going
with the officer's
recommendation thank you is that a
second
okay um so we've had a a range of views
and I had a fairly open debate would
anyone else like to contribute at this
point or are we going to move to the
vote no move to the vote okay uh in
which case we have a proposal um which
has been seconded to refuse application
in line with officers
recommendations can I see all those in
favor that's fine five
opposed that's five in which case
casting vote is mine and uh the
application is refused so application
23842 ful is
refused okay thank
you
okay then we can now move on to the next
item which is uh item four application
23 SL
01872 Land north of marriage Hill
bidford on aen our presenting officer is
Rano Keith uh when you are ready take it
away thank you chairman and good evening
the application site is within the
settlement of bidford on Haven as
denoted by the black dot on the
map
sorry what's
on the application site is within the
settlement of bidford aen and within its
B plan commission was originally granted
in 2022 under
22/10 71 ful for the development of free
dwellings on on this site this
permission is extant with Works
commenced on
site this application seeks to vary
conditions two of plan of this plan
mission to revise the plan the parking
layout and changes to the layout and
elevations of the proposed
dwellings in regards to plot one you've
got the approved scheme on the left hand
side and the proposed scheme to the
right hand
side the majority of the changes are
internal in terms of replanning a
staircase and altering the third floor
plan to four bedrooms from the three
bedrooms previously approved with roof
lights above the
garage to serve new on suites with a
higher ease level to accommodate
such
in regards to plot two again internally
the staircase and the thir floor plan is
altered to
accommodate um a new master bedroom and
minor amendments to window positions to
suit the revised
changes again revision to plot three
mainly internal in terms of planning the
internal staircase and the first floor
to go to four bedrooms from the three
bedrooms
approved and again similar development
to the Gage with the E height uh raised
slightly to accommodate the on suite and
roof
lights as indicated on this photo you
can see Works obviously well underway on
the site at
present again another view taking inside
site with construction near nearing
first floor
level and looking down the access Drive
um that accesses the
site the recommendation is to Grant the
variational condition uh subject to the
condition set out within the officer
report thank you very much R okay we now
move on to our first Speaker who is
Elizabeth ugal
hopefully I pronounced that somewhere
near the
right
no feel feel free to correct me um you
have three minutes I'm happy to give you
a 30 second warning yeah okay should be
right that ready please take good
evening the parish council objected to
the above development on two occasions
last year in September in October on the
grounds of safety a dangerous access and
loss of agricultural land at the time
council did not deem it necessary to
stress the house miss mix as it hoped
committee would consider the safety
aspect and loss of agricultural land is
sufficient to deny permission however
this committee disagreed and gave
permission for three three-bedroom
dwellings 12 months later A variation on
the granted application has been
submitted instead of three three-bedroom
dwellings applicants applicants now want
to build two four bedrooms and only one
three-bedroom it should be mentioned
that when the variation application was
sent to the parish council the first
time it stated the variation submitted
was to change one of the three bedrooms
to a one four bedroom on looking at the
app at the application this was clearly
incorrect the amendment was for two
times 4 bedrooms and one times three
bedroom I am aware that I'm repeating
this but it is important to note as
Council does not agree that the
variation proposes minor changes to the
original permission it is changing
2third of the original permission hardly
a minor change Council recognizes that
maow mix is difficult to apply to a
small development such as this however
the principle remains and whereas the
requirement for three-bedroom dwellings
is
45% this reduces to 10% for bedroom four
bedroom dwellings clearly demonstrating
the higher need for the three-bedroom
dwelling planning should be considered
on the needs of the local community
not the profit of the developers and on
this basis Council strongly believes
that the greater need is for
three-bedroom dwellings and therefore
this variation should not be
granted thank you very much well within
your time members do we have any
questions for our Parish Council
representative councilor Harvey first I
believe thank you I'm just interested to
know whether you've done a housing needs
survey recently and what that said yeah
and that exactly it's it's that is BAS
basically two two and three bedrooms is
what is required we had to do it for the
NDP I believe councilor keithly next
thanks shair same question so thank you
for
answering very good uh any further
questions for our Parish
Council
no or or S similar mind then um oh quick
one from Castle keatley quick one yeah
you did mention I think at the beginning
some safe issues could you just
elaborate on those why those would why
those are any different to the three
properties still no that wasn't it's
just that we did not stress at the time
of the original application the house
makes at the time because we didn't we
didn't think that was going to be the
important thing we thought the important
thing would be that permission shouldn't
be given on the basis of loss of
agricultural land and an a unsafe access
which by the way means that nothing is
supposed to be happening on this
development until that is signed
off so okay so the original your
original objection was based on loss of
agricultural land yes I did say that at
the beginning that that was why we did
not mention um house mix originally
because that was not the top of the
agenda at that okay thanks that's
cleared up that you didn't object on the
basis of house mix you accepted three
three beds we didn't accept it because
we didn't want it to happen you didn't
object to but I did say the reason why
thank you thank you uh any further
questions from Paris counselor no in
which case thank you very much for
contribution this
evening very good uh we now move on then
to our next speaker who is Helen low on
behalf of the
applicant good
evening uh so we've also got three
minutes I'm happy to give you a 30
second warning um otherwise it's uh the
button on the right hand side and uh
feel free to start whenever you're
ready thank you chair uh good evening
everybody I'm Helen low director at Stan
gate planning I'm here speaking on
behalf of the applicant Mr McDermot um
the application as you've heard seeks to
make a number of minor amendments to the
previously approved and extent
permission for three detached dwellings
to the rear of sford Road and harbor
close as you've heard that the changes
will involve improvements to the car
parking arrangements to ensure
compliance with the development
requirements SPD altered patio areas uh
small changes to some of the windows and
roof lights to serve bathrooms and some
internal alterations to enable the
creation of an additional bedroom in
plots one and three there's no
additional changes to plot two the
majority of the works if carried out
following the substantial completion of
the current permission would not
constitute development and would
therefore fall outside the remit of the
planning system however the applicant is
seeking to incorporate these changes at
the time of construction in order to
minimize waste from subsequent
alterations the development requirements
SPD recognizes that achieving a fully
policy compliant housing mix on sites of
less than 10 dwellings may not be
practicable in this instance where only
three dwellings are proposed in an edge
of settlement location obtaining a mixed
compliant with the SPD core strategy
policy n um cs19 or policy H3 of the
bidford neighborhood plan is not
practicable the Strategic housing market
assessment dates from 2015 and is now
outdated and the more recent local
housing needs survey for bib for aen
certainly the one available on the
council's website dates from 2017 and
indicated a need for two three bed
Market homes and two four bed Market
homes whilst the survey is now quite
dated it does show that a similar level
of need existed for both three and
four-bedroom Market
houses the overall size footprint and
floor space of each of the dwellings
would not exceed those already approved
the proposed changes merely look to make
make a more efficient and familyfriendly
internal layout for the homes and could
there could have been a change from
studies to bedrooms um post Construction
in any event members may recall a
similar situation with a scheme of six
dwellings on part of the King Edwards
School playing field site at Manor Road
where all six homes were proposed as
four-bedroom dwellings whilst the
council refused permission here the
inspector in allowing the subsequent
appeal found no concerns or conflict
with all of those properties being four
bedrooms
the proposed amendments would not result
in any material changes to the external
appearance of the
property uh which would appear almost
identical to those approved similarly
the proposed amendments would not create
any adverse impacts upon neighboring
residents just to finish in respect of
condition 8 which is the relation to the
access from the highway as mentioned by
the parish council Works to widen the
access to six meters have been
undertaken and the outstanding aspects
relate to the final connection and drop
curb they were delayed temporarily
because of Seven Trent but should be
finished this week thank you for your
time hang on time thank you very much
members do we have any questions counc H
serin thank you um can you tell me why
you've changed your mind from granting
three three bedroom houses to two four
bedroom and one three bedroom what's the
real reason it it's simply a better use
of the space that's inside you know you
got the housing survey which requires
the three and two bedroom
so but the the space inside the
dwellings I don't if you've looked at
the the plans from the previously
approved ones you've got some very large
bathroom spaces um and the staircase in
the middle is not um it's not creating
the most usable space so it's simply a
case of you can fit four bedrooms in
easily and that seems a reasonable
solution thank you any further questions
councelor Keithley uh yeah a question
Helen thank you um um the parish council
objected and commented that the would
variations should be not considered
until this condition 8 is discharged you
just can I just clarify you said that
the the access now has been widened in
accordance with the plans apart from the
last little bit on onto the road with
the curb is that that's that's the case
that's my understanding I've been
informed by the applicant who obviously
been on site today that seven Trent
finished their Works which were causing
the the blockage if you like uh no pun
intended um that they finished their
works on Monday and so they've been able
to they'll be able to finish those Works
to today um tomorrow Friday this week so
that access issue is sorted thank you
very much councilor Harvey this is a
slight tongue and- cheek question but
but why are you only asking for
variation in relation to two why you
asking for variation into all three to
make them into three four
bedrooms well the plot two is a smaller
property just
impracticable thank you any further
questions no in which case thank you
very much for your
contribution okay we now move on then to
our final speaker who is the W member
councelor
Fleming good evening
counselor obviously you've got five
minutes happy to give you a 30 second
war no jolly good in which case uh you
know the drill and when you're ready
take it
away thanks for the opportunity to speak
uh this has been sort of um derided as a
as a minor and trivial uh thing to
object to but um from the uh from the
perspective of local knowledge shall we
say um the condition on the entrance I
don't think has been signed off we've
already been through that with the
parish Clark and with the with the agent
um the whole idea that was that nothing
was due to start on the site until that
was done and the reason for that
is um exactly outside this
driveway um that's going to house these
these houses um it's the assembly point
for school buses in the morning and in
the afternoon so on average you've got
50 to 60 kids Milling about outside this
this particular uh access
point if you go from three bedrooms to
four bedrooms it means that you've got a
fair chance that the family will be
bigger and there will be more cars hence
the reason one of the reasons for
changing the car parking so this access
emerges out over a foot path because
outside the house there is a wide grass
Verge so it's got a runup driveway it
crosses a live foot path and that was
one of the big big objections to it in
the first place now if you put more
bigger bedrooms you can have bigger
families you can have more cars going in
and out of there and uh as far as uh
local knowledge is concerned that's
going to be a difficult thing um
because the uh the number of school
children is only going to increases time
so it moves on um so from that perspect
there there's been one close call but
I've got no I've got no written proof of
all of that happening so I can't really
bring that up but there has been a close
call already um a housing need survey
that we did a few years ago shows we
want three bedrooms and four bedrooms on
the adjacent site to this uh where we've
got 190 houses built in the last 3 to
four years there are four four bedroom
houses for sale on that estate and two
five bedroom houses for sale on that
estate so the need for four bedroom
houses in bidford doesn't exist because
there are plenty of them um so from that
ex that's the reason I'm objecting um
they're unnecessary they're not required
we've got a housing survey that says we
need three bedroom houses so we've got
permission for three-bedroom houses so
let's have three bedroom houses that's
all thank
you thank you very much councelor uh
members do we have any questions for our
Ward member councel Keithley yes thank
you very much councilor Fleming could
you tell me if you know anything you
mentioned the safety aspect of the
entrance I see that war County Council
highways are not objected to this
have you had any discussions about those
points with maybe the parish council or
the highways
Department not recently um at at the at
the beginning of this situation um War
County Council highways objected to it
um and then um they came out did some
more measurements and whatever else uh
and uh they came they got involved and
then withdrew their objection because if
they hadn't withdrawn their objection
the planning permission would never have
happened so so they did object in the
initial stages um we don't think the
fact that they withdrew the objection
was a good thing because there is still
the danger
there any further questions for our war
member no in which case thank you very
much okay members we now move on to uh
points of clarification from our
officers um I'm going to start with um
just a couple um very briefly uh with
regards condition 8 which was referenced
by the ward member there um does that
need sign
off no to confirm the wording of the
condition is a compliance condition so
there's no need for the applicant to
have put anything in to be formly
discharged by the LPA thank you uh and
the other one which I was going to ask
um much has been referenced in regard to
the uh housing needs survey um when that
was and and what it showed was the need
within bidford uh could you just sort of
elaborate on some details of what we've
got for that please
of course so um as the agent referred to
the most recent housing needs survey
which is on our website is dated 2017 so
would be regarded as as out of date at
this point um I know the parish
counselor made reference to the NDP and
that a housing need survey was
undertaken off the back of that um I've
had a look at the wording of the NDP and
it states that the last housing KNE
survey was conducted in 2012 and
provided an analysis of local housing
need at the time of writing since 2012 a
significant number of market and
affordable homes have been granted Ed
many of which have been built but a
large number have yet to be built a
review of local housing need will be
undertaken within the first 5 years of
the adoption of the NDP through an
up-to-date housing need survey so to my
mind based on the contents of the NDP
there hasn't been a more up-to-date
housing need survey
undertaken okay thank you councilor
pton thank you
um I um could the office to bring up
intern have you got some uh the internal
layouts can you show show me the
internal layouts for the change to the
three to the four three to four beds for
the two properties
please I'm assuming we we must have that
in
there so what I'll show you first is
plot one so this is be approved and what
I'll do is I'll um can you yeah zoom in
on it yeah hang
AE
do get the
second
so this is the approved um first floor
plan for plot
one um so 8 11 and 12 will the
bedrooms and do you have dimensions for
those I don't have the dimensions but in
terms of the change um I'll refer back
to
um so this is what they're proposing um
so first floor the staircase is
obviously um altered so in a sense
bedroom so Sor yeah sorry is this what's
proposed yeah
[Music]
no this is proposed no oh yeah because
it's that's why
um hang that's why
because if I do
it there we go sorry apologies about
that um so this is a proposed so where I
indicated that number eight on the
approved drawing has now been split to
make two
bedrooms um the staircase in the middle
is altered and then bedroom one is
reconfigured so a lot of the space was
already there they've just obviously
altered it um this is the same for plot
three because it's the same layout
as plot one can I
just
yeah sorry ter terribly sorry chairman
that's what's proposed can I compare
that with what was approved yeah what
I'll
do
because I'm going to do it this
way there we
go so so right hand side I'll move my
little window is what we approved and
the left hand side is what they
proposed and just to clarify you can't
give any Dimensions here for the
smallest bedroom I haven't got that in
hand
now I'm
sorry okay uh any further points
clarification C keithly thanks
chair uh yeah we heard from the Ward
member that um traffic and safety on
site was an issue and that warshire
County Council highways originally
objected um can you can you just clarify
that was the case and what were the
grounds for them um withdrawing that
objection that's the first part my
question and the second bit of the
question is how many more traffic
movements do you think there would be by
adding two extra bedrooms in this
development in answer to your first
question we haven't received we didn't
initially receive an objection to this
application so I'm imagining that it's
referring to previous applications I am
just going to double check that before I
confirm it yeah we've only had the one
response to this application which is
one of no objection in response to the
previous application which this one is
seeking to
vary I can see that County
highways I can only see that they raise
no
objection tell a lie they originally
objected and the original objection was
based
on uh at the entrance of the access the
width measures 3.9 M the highway
Authority is unsure if this is a width
of the total length of the access track
or if it decreases in width closer to
the proposed dwellings so about highways
um the the width of the access uh a
concern regarding pedestrian visibility
spays concerns about construction
traffic and then the no objection goes
on to say that these matters have been
addressed and therefore no objection was
raised subject to conditions that
reflects obviously this current
application where they've raised no
objection thank you uh further points
clarification cely was the second
question which was traffic movements in
relation to two extra bedrooms on this
development I'm I'm just going to assume
it would be
minor um I would assume it's minor um if
it um had been an issue I assume that
highways would have picked it up on
their
response and we would have addressed any
um objection if if they had
that thank you Council Harvey just to
labor the point what you're telling us
is that the highways Authority in
relation to the original application
which was for nine bedrooms didn't
comment upon the volume of traffic and
now that it's a variation seeking to
increase the 9 to 11 they still haven't
commented upon the volume of traffic is
that
correct yeah that's
correct
thank you any further points
clarification no in which case we can
move to debate uh who would like to
start councelor
Eden thank you chair um I remember this
one from when it came around the first
time or two
um my problem I fully sympathize with
with the ward member of the Parish Clerk
because everything about this the first
time round felt a little bit not quite
right um
however um the applicants managed to
overcome the issues of the highways
um and all the other issues which um
were bought up back then I can't see
anything particularly firm here um that
can sway me otherwise or I can use to
argue against the variation of this
condition to be honest and the officers
report about uh States on page 23 that
it would not result in material or
additional harm the variation so to my
mind I I feel like I've got to go with
granting this one um I won't propose
just yet let's see if anyone's got
anything else
but thank you very much councel
pton thank you chair um I take a
different view to councelor Ed and I do
find myself uh playing that role tonight
um this is
contrived um and I have significant
concerns about the impact of the amenity
of the residents of the
properties um we're shoehorning four
bedrooms into a space for three um I'm I
I'm not sure I agree with the officer's
uh assessment that the uh that suggests
that the The Source evidence for the NDP
is out of date um it is is clear the NDP
the NDP and and the mix within the NDP
has has has never been successfully
challenged so the 20% for beds um is it
hasn't been challenged historically um
the NDP and the housing need survey um
if they've been superseded they've been
superseded by the uh additionality in
terms of development in bidford over and
above the numbers proposed in the core
strategy and that addition ality F did
focus a significant increase in four and
five bed houses and the ward member is
absolutely right that there is uh a
surfit of such properties um and across
the piece not just in bidford and
bidford is a main Rural Center um we are
looking for smaller properties one two
and three bed and if members recall the
state of the district report we we
congratulated ourselves on delivering
78% free bed um and we're we're
proposing to to go over and above that
I'm also concerned that where is the
difference where is a variation versus a
new application in the sense of in
essence you're increasing the number of
bedrooms by 20% I know it's 9 to 11 my
main reason against this is I think that
there
is there is an impact on the immunity of
the occupi of the house
by having a contrived four bed layout
when actually these are designed as
three beds they they are good three beds
and we should support good design and I
think you know we all understand the
rationale of shoehorn in the extra
bedroom and it takes it up a bracket
sales-wise I think we should consider
the immunity of those who purchase and I
would be against the variation on that
as a ground I I acknowledge the uh the
the access issue is has sailed there
isn't anything in the terms of
potentially the additional traffic but I
do think the residential immunity of the
occupiers um is something that does need
to be is a is a is a significant in my
wait waiting of the application thank
you thank you councelor Harvey can I
just raise a question as councelor pemon
has raised the issue of this adequacy of
size of the bedrooms um Can the officers
tell us whether the proposed uh
variation uh and the resulting size of
bedrooms meets standard requirements or
not
in a very broad brush we consider that
the the sizes of the bed bedrooms are
sufficient um we could check them
against ndss standards but that will
just take a couple of
minutes I don't know whether you want to
continue and we can come back to that or
if it's key to the determination I'd be
quite happy to have that information but
um both Council Harvey and pton look to
be itching to
speak
I would just make the point that I have
no doubt it'll meet the space standard
they're not that daed just think it's
you know but we haven't slavishly got to
follow if we if it if it works like a
duck and quacks it's a duck it's it's a
contrived screw four had four beds into
a three bed house and I think we can
take a view about the loss of immunity
even if it does meet the space standard
we we should be we should be aspiring
for better than the space
standard thank Council
Holmes in in principle I do have to
agree with a lot of what um Council
pemon saying I mean it's unfortunate
that a lot of the development in in the
district has been primarily big
executive homes and there hasn't been
enough of the three and two and one
bedroom houses that that that there
needs to be but my only worry is I don't
I don't see an an a lesson come comes up
now that if we do go against it all
that's going to happen is it's going to
go to appeal and it'll go through anyway
um that that's my only
concern thank you councel Holmes
councelor Keith next well I'd like the
information I think i' I'd really like
if we're going to make a decision based
upon whether or not residential amuni is
impacted by small bedrooms I think we
need to know what we're talking
about if I can come in for a moment just
to clarify so the nationally described
space standards
provide floor areas for a four bed uh
twostory dwelling as being should be a
minimum of 97 square meters so I'll
check that in a moment um so that's sh
figure we're looking
for I'm just checking whether there are
actual sizes for the bedrooms I don't
know off the top of my head so I'm just
going to read through the
guidance what doing that I believe
councelor scorer
we're on thank you um I sympathize with
the ward member and the uh the clerk of
the parish council but I think we're
just holding off the the obvious really
because even if they were marketed as a
three-bedroom in time you know
somebody's going to take that and
actually we can make it a four four
bedroom so I think we're just holding
off the uh what's going to
happen chair was Observe that we must
put we must consider what is in front of
us not what might be done at some point
further down the track thank you Council
pton well noted um would anyone else
like to contribute um prior to us
getting the information from our
officers on sizes no in which case we'll
just wait for
that uh thank you for your way everyone
um so looking at the space stands like I
say for a four bed um dwelling the
minimum twostory uh floor space should
be 97 square met the floor area of the
I've done plot one because I think
they're probably comparable is 160 so it
is in excess of That 160 so the absolute
minimum is 97 it measures as 160 it's
not quite so clear in terms of size of
bedrooms it basically says that for a
single bedroom a floor area should have
at least 7.5 M uh for a double it should
have 11.5 M I've check the smallest
bedroom and it's 10.6 square
meters so hopefully that helps to
clarify matters but like I say officers
aren't concerned with the the size of
the bedrooms or the houses thank you
very much for that Alice um Okay so
we've had quite a bit of debate already
um we haven't had a formal proposal as
of yet I see a council councelor Eden
itching uh thank you chair hardly
itching
however um I I see nowhere else to go
other than to propose that we go with
officers recommendations to
Grant thank you councelor
Eden Council Keithley yeah thanks chair
um I can understand why Council of pton
feels it's a bit contrived the question
I would ask is why didn't they go for
four bedrooms in the first place um
given that there was no restrictions in
terms of the mix on a development of
just three houses the um objections in
respect of the road or the uh the access
and the width of the access seem to be
overcome and I feel uh having just heard
the um the space available for four
bedrooms 160 square meters when the
minimum standard is just under 100 I
think we'd be on shaky GR round to go
against the officer's recommendation so
I would second councelor Eden's proposal
on
this thank you very much any further
contribution no um I will I haven't
added to the debate as of yet I when
this came through I was on the committee
at that point as well and I completely
sympathized with the with the parish
council then in fact I I remember voting
against it at the time on on a number of
grounds obviously none of which uh stood
up to the test of policy and I think
that's ultimately what we have to look
at um it's plain that members around the
table don't like necessarily what we see
but we have policy um and what that is
telling us is that this is acceptable um
and ultimately that's what's driving us
so uh we have a proposal and a second um
for uh granting in line with the officer
recommendations can I see all those in
favor please
that would be eight
opposed don't blame you at all uh in
which case
um committee moves to Grant application
SLV
um application
6f uh 30 Road Bishops itchington
are presenting officer Sarah Lee when
you're ready take it away
thank you chairman good evening this Pro
this proposal is seeking Planning
Commission for a replacement rear
boundary fence to 30 Dlow Road located
within the village of Bishop itchington
the application site can be identified
by the black
dot the application site is located in a
residential area with dwellings to each
boundary this aerial photo shows the
application site and its surroundings
this photo was taken in 2021 and is the
most upto-date aerial photo available
able the house sorry the Housing
Development to the south of the site has
now been
completed here we have the existing and
proposed elevations the proposed fence
would be approximately 1.1 M taller than
the existing fence this is to overcome
land level changes between the host
property and the new development at the
rear here are some photos of the
application site the fence in these
photos is the rear fence of 45 Ione
way there would be some public views of
the rear fence from the new Housing
Development to the
south in these photos um you can see the
differing land levels with the
neighboring property uh to the rear
sighting being
higher uh the officer recommendations to
Grant this application subject to the
conditions and notes out in the
report thank you very much uh Sarah uh
we move on to our first and only speaker
who is is councelor Kettle from Bishop
hington Parish
Council welcome
councelor thank you for being with us um
you have three minutes uh we'll know you
know the drill um thank you free this is
a bit of a sorry Tale the larger State
you can see behind you in the picture
was granted an appeal statford District
Council having refused this and another
application for the site um however the
parish council did negotiate with the
developer that if he was to
succeed um the houses immediately in
front of this row of houses we're
looking at would all be Bungalows to
minimize the impact on the Outlook from
the existing hous in dagow
Road when the final application was put
in uh and the parish council were not
experts the ground
level um was going to be raised by 1 and
a half meters so all those Bungalows
were actually going to be considerably
higher than we in in en visaged at the
beginning um the condition was that
there would be fencing close boarded
fencing put in front of the old houses
to protect them from the new which is
fine except for that for that for this
property the ground level drops so 1
point I think 8 m fence Set uh probably
about a meter below the level of the
house gives it no protection whatsoever
from um the occupi the new
properties um a former head of the
planning service here came to visit the
site and express concern but there was
nothing we could do about it that stage
and therefore this application has come
forward with the support of statford
District Council which is why it's in
front of the planning committee tonight
with the support of the parish council
with the support of the officer um to
allow what is significantly higher
boarding that would normally be the case
but it is to protect the the um well
reinstate what should should have been
there if the boarding had been put at a
proper level all the way across and the
effectively what's been happened has
been put in a ditch that was there
before that hasn't been filled in whilst
everything else has been filled in so
I'd recommend uh members of the
committee everybody is supporting this
the only reason it's here because the
application is actually um It Is by Mr W
the occupier but it is being supported
by the District Council planning team
and I'd very much hope you could sport
it
tonight thank you very much members do
we have any questions Council keatley
thank you councilor Kettle um could you
just tell us whether or not there are
any other properties similarly affected
by the overlooking from the new
development uh this is slightly unique
this property well a I I I mean I've
been in and out of this Garden many
times um the other neighbors have not
had the same concern because the ground
level drops significantly and if you
look at the picture immediately in front
of Mr W's
house um that there was a subsequent
application to change that property from
a bungalow to a two-story
house just answer the question we don't
need the whole
story no uh the answer is the ground
level drops and therefore this is much
the bottom end of this Garden is much
lower so this is the only property
councelor kettle that's what you're
saying this the only one that thank you
very much indeed it's helpful thank
thank you um councilors any further
questions no in which case councelor
Kettle thank you very much for your
contribution um we will move on to
points of clarification councelor I have
no points of clarification i' I'd like
to move the recommendation to Grant I
thought you might say that um looks like
we're moving into the debate we have a
proposal to Grant councilor Keithley did
you want to come in I would thank you
chair yeah I I I think it's Dreadful
shame that these people are having to
live um with that overlooking in the
back Garden so I'd like to Second The
Proposal look at the councilor pton to
Grant thank you very much any further
contribution uh no in which case
proposal to Grant which has been
seconded can I see all those in favor
please unanimous unanimous in which case
committee resolves to Grant application
6fl um is there any urgent business no
urgent business in which case meeting's
closed thank you very
much